cinco madrugadas consecutivas de
temperaturas negativas con termómetros
indicando hasta -9 grados celsius en
algunas regiones de francia en plena
primavera una caída brutal de
temperaturas que normalmente sólo se ve
en invierno los vergeles de ciruela
durazno o kiwi y albaricoques fueron
particularmente afectados por segundo
año consecutivo y también el que
experimentamos en 2021 ese es el
desastre llevamos dos años seguidos con
heladas extremas y aunque estamos
equipados aunque hayamos invertido no
tenemos la cosecha para récord con un
mes de marzo especialmente caliente los
árboles habían empezado sus floración es
más temprano de lo normal poniendo los
brotes en peligro ahora algunos cultivos
están devastados al 80% pero la
corte todo iba bien veíamos que íbamos a
tener una buena cosecha porque había un
número suficiente de frutos pero todo se
acabó en una hora pasamos de una buena
promesa a un fracaso sabiendo que ya hay
un año de trabajo para conseguirlo el
itec
los agricultores intentaron proteger sus
árboles con varias técnicas y solo aquí
tenemos torres de viento tenemos velas
pero lo que mejor funciona en la
pulverización es decir proteger cultivos
con agua y sabemos qué es lo que mejor
funciona de venir sin embargo son
métodos costosos que no garantizan
resultados el estado ya desbloqueó 20
millones de ayuda para los agricultores
afectados pero las pérdidas podrían
revelarse peores en los próximos meses